let's do it
i'm already set i should probably be
here right
hello and welcome to this beautiful
gamespot now playing of hitman the beta
set on playstation 4 today it's out on
pc seven days from now today is the 12th
of february in case you're wondering and
i'm here in the new gamespot streaming
room i've never been here before my
favorite part by the way is this wall
back here because it looks like the
texture hasn't loaded yet
it's just like this pla it's like oh
[ __ ] somebody somebody call up on real
engine we can fix this i'm here to play
hitman i haven't played the new hitman
yet i'm a huge fan of the series
hey man back in 2000
hit one two and blood money are my
favorites
i wasn't actually that hot on absolution
but i'm looking forward to this new
hitman game it's coming out
uh
relatively soon in this weird sort of
way it was supposed to come out back in
december it's coming in march supposed
to come back back in december originally
they had this crazy plan
to release the game and then have sort
of uh like a bunch of
downloadable missions that would happen
after the fact
and it kind of changed a bit now they're
going to release the game as like this
starter pack and then release
the rest of the game episodically so the
game's going to launch but i believe
this mission a paris mission which i
think is the one that looks like
zoolander we've seen a bunch of and then
after that and like the months
afterwards they're going to release a
bunch of content you can basically buy
the starter pack or you can buy like the
whole digital game and get all that
stuff uh bundled in it or you can just
opt in and purchase the stuff
as it's coming like a la carte and then
sometime in the future in 2016
they're going to release
like a physical copy with everything on
it so like
i imagine this has a lot to do with them
you know square enix trying out the
different type of delivery method this
is kind of hitman like oh man
fans know that this is a game that is
quite modular like you can kind of play
the levels
different from each other like some of
the games sort of tied together a little
bit more like absolution did and blood
money but like a lot of them are it's a
pretty modular game so it kind of works
but i imagine it also has a lot to do
with the fact that this game has already
slipped a bunch and that they're just
trying to get them out like let's it's a
content heavy game when it comes to
what they're doing
because these environments are so rich
so i kind of get it
wait one of my ears just go think one of
my uses
oh whatever i don't need to hear what's
over happening over that side uh let's
get into the game enough for the irish
guy talking here we are hitman beta
press x to play like i said i've never
actually played this so uh
sorry i haven't played this new one
it's also irritating me it's only called
hitman
i played it man 16 years ago
i'm old
that's reminding me square
here we go
so this beta is open for folks who have
uh pre-ordered the game
and also uh
ooh look my sem membership is going to
open up a browser window no all right
don't worry about oh we can't record
this oh don't worry about it square
we're recording this anyway
um all right stupid membership [ __ ] do
not care about that
what else we got
so from what i know this whole area
that they have
is
like a it's like it's a pre it's a
prequel and it's basically
him arriving
as tobias reaper i guess
back at the start like before the
original hitman as far as i know
this menu is a [ __ ] nightmare i'll
just say that right now
objectives
arrival great play
let's do it let's get into the game
welcome to everyone twitch shot
watching on gamespot.com thanks for
hanging there federer dave
has sons there
acro master
by the game get one mission and we add
one more every month for a year is a
real shitty strategy it is a strange way
of going about it i feel like
these types of games i feel like i don't
play for a whole year i feel like there
are games that you binge on hard for a
month or two and then you kind of you
gotta disconnect so it's gonna be
interesting to see how they pull this
off
i imagine a lot of people would go for
the intro pack
20 years earlier
let me know if the game plays too loud
and his bald heads never look so good
and then gameplan
this looks pretty
i'll say that right now this looks real
pretty
i think you guys are seeing in 30. it's
running on 60 here it's pretty good
also looks like the uh
it's gonna be a real deep cup this looks
like the music video for corns
uh
i forget which song the one that's got
the german doctor in it hey what's up
i mean you don't really need security
that tight when you have a base up in
the middle of the himalayas or wherever
this is
majestic isn't it
i'm diana i'll take you to your quarters
oh hi diana someone likes to keep
secrets
secrets are our stock and trade besides
from what i hear you have a few of your
own i'm not like you in case you're
wondering i'm in the handler program
i've got hair agents and handlers work
in unity
you know the expression know your enemy
well
that part is my job no your enemies only
have the victory i know i wasn't added
you also need to know yourself ooh frame
rate i'm working on it this is a beta i
read your case file impressive work
thank you partly textbook but i suppose
field work never is
yeah i've been working at gamestop for
15 years but i really think killing
people is gonna
random
disorder ooh
is that why you came here
why you let us test you it's a bit out
of sync maybe i'm not the only one being
tested
well
we are here basic training starts at
over 600 hours
six in the morning jesus
leave you to prepare yeah i just took a
helicopter up to the [ __ ] mountains
you want to give me a lie in maybe
geez lady six in the morning
are you sure about this i am there are
no second chances miss burnwood not here
i choose him
may i inquire why
a blank slate antisocial
apathetic and unresponsive bald no doubt
the boy shows promise but perhaps i see
possibility where others see limitation
isn't that what happened this is
rewriting the hitman's
canon in a way that i do not appreciate
he still remembers nothing if he does
he's not sharing i don't like this
alopecia loner in romania [ __ ]
clone
keep him under close watch
i don't know
uh z9
panic i believe we can come to advanced
training show as much as we want your
first mission originally took place in
sydney australia
the target was calvin ritter also known
as the sparrow
master thief for hire specializing in
rare and priceless art sweet monitor
agent cleverly infiltrated ritter's
private yacht during a social gathering
and discreetly eliminated him without
any of the guests noticing
now you will do the same great oh and
don't worry about the training
operatives all weapons are simulated
good luck oh weapons are simulated i'm
gonna blow somebody's [ __ ] head off
and i'm gonna see if this game
see how simulated it is okay so this is
the beta so i'm guessing it's gonna be
super super hand holdy and will not be
super representative of uh
of the normal
ways in which this game plays i do love
the fact that this is a training center
and they have put up
like
the sunset and hired easily 300 people
for this top secret training center to
play as actors
great why not
also okay can we just take a moment to
appreciate the fact that in the original
hitman game this guy he was called to
buy his reaper in the first game i don't
think he was after the fact
he was a clone
which is why he had the bar code and why
he was called agent 47 because they've
made like loads of them spoilers uh i
love the fact that he's just a dude now
he's just a sociopath who decides to fit
a [ __ ] barcode
and then the cia wherever the hell they
say they're like yeah sure sure
i mean
you're clearly not able to
make life decisions about tattoos but
yeah sure we'll bring you into our super
secret organization anyway okay
can i just walk can i just
you're not let on board your current
outfit
okay understood classic hitman uh having
a costume on will allow you access
to certain areas
it might
make people
less suspicious of you might also make
me people more suspicious of me
sometimes
watch a little bit more i'm trespassing
oh look at this guy hi viz jacket
circle to take cover
um all right take him down from behind
just how i like it
oh [ __ ]
don't worry about me bro hey what the
hell are you doing here
whatever it's fine uh okay so i guess
this snapping to cover mechanic needs a
little bit to be desired
so there's that one is it based on where
i am
snap
yeah i don't know doesn't seem super
uh
snap neck sure yeah whatever
jesus christ
all right
great put on his clothes i love a hat
man that's a first i just snapped that
actor's neck for no reason people do
tend to see uniforms not faces
some people are more observant than
others hide him in the toilet
there's a big toilet for a construction
site i'm actually really impressed this
guy's must have a good union uh close no
close that yep all right let's drop him
i mean no one ever goes to the toilet so
let's put him there perfect
oh [ __ ]
move your legs
just dragging his face along the ground
oh magic doors all right
all right i like airplanes it's it's i
like how controls i will say this the
covering snap thing is a little bit
annoying and in a game where you're
like where
your positioning is so important that
that might be a little bit irritating
but
maybe it was just the first time
i guess we'll find it soon enough all
right
it's good to get a cap as well because
if like another ball dude walks up and
then suddenly
okay how do i stand the [ __ ] up again
there you go
circle all right interesting clicking in
the thumbstick picks him up but hitting
circle again doesn't all right hey
what's up guys
hey hey doing yeah i'm just gonna i'm
dressed to impress that's what
press r1 to interact don't use instinct
okay here we go batman vision
there's our target over there
there's a bunch of people
all of which are actors apparently and
totally know that i'm a killer
hey you're on the repairman hey
don't touch me whoa okay jesus calm the
[ __ ] down without escalated sorry dude
i'm just a repairman
i know i'm supposed to go see that deal
but i just want to wander around here
and see all these actors look at these
guys
what's going on how you doing folks
it's me the assassin
i mean the repair man
repairman he probably trades on the side
let's listen in on their conversations
or our generous host is a criminal
all right i kind of just want to punch
one of these oh my god the pool is fake
oh my god i love this game
i love this game ah
hey everyone
look
i'm breaking the laws of physics
look i'm
i
i'm i'm jesus christ son of god look i'm
walking okay sorry i'm gonna go back to
work
you guys are really in character
okay
all right where's our boy r1 he's over
there
follow the target
so the best thing about the hitman games
is if you want
you can just start punching the [ __ ] out
of people
and you're probably gonna get shot
pretty quickly
yeah good good to hear it bro uh
so you have to figure out smart ways
you're too sensitive i was walking fast
that's weird
uh or yeah yeah you can figure out
different sort of ingenious ways to to
kill the people
uh what usually happens is you end up
losing the game you're like you mess up
your go like four or five times then you
eventually figure out like where people
walk and how to kill people and
when they're like oh can i go up there
and when the best opportunity to murder
them
this is gonna be messy if we let the
mechanics through here so uh you need to
go back
okay i'm sorry
so i've gotten on to the yacht so i
guess the next thing i got to do is
disguise myself with someone else
like this guy
throwing items throwing blood items if
people will knock them out oh mate this
is gonna be fun
can i save
i'm not actually just interested in like
oh i can't you could do hard saves on if
you want oh i'm going to love this game
all right let me just make sure that was
actually done
you never know i'm playing xcom 2 at the
moment guys you can never know you just
gotta
you gotta make double sure you got those
saves locked in all right which blunt
item should we throw at him we got okay
the game is telling me hammer
but i mean
this plant
come on let me pick something else up
wrench hammer
this guy doesn't seem to care i'm just
wandering around all right can i pick
what about the
this maybe
enter
don't mind me bro
hey
hey when this guy comes when this guy
comes to get some more gorgonzola it's
really going to freak him in all right
check it out just checking the
checking the
the afraid the freezer is working the
way there's gonna use this wrench and
throw it at his [ __ ] head all right
oh so it locks interesting when i hold
old l2 it literally locks onto him
so i guess i can i'm just gonna oh okay
so i can i can manually throw it but if
i
go on him it's gonna unlock it all right
yeah delicious like this [ __ ] ah
we're snap neck
okay i'm gonna snap everyone's leg the
thing that's going to happen though is
that the game is going to like when i'm
finished doing my
where's the hi-vis jacket can i use the
hi-vis jacket again unlike
okay the cabin crew is allowed upstairs
access
i see what you're getting at
very early delicious i like it
uh yeah what's gonna happen is they're
gonna say you did a great job but like
did you really have to
kill all those people like snap their
necks like was that completely necessary
i don't know
all right can i walk around with this
wrench in my hand is it weird for the
cook to walk around with a ranch
maybe i don't know let's find out
together
i uh
gotta go this way
like i just said greetings mariner oh
that's beautiful
what's going on there's a lot of people
in these crowds sometimes if i just walk
through them
sorry i'm the captain i can do what i
want sorry i'm the captain
sorry it's been sorry captain duties
captain duties yep just gonna yep don't
mind me
oh [ __ ] people are noticing me
people are noticing me being weird
i better stop
hey it's me the cook
hey
yeah it's got this wrench don't worry
about it
upstairs this sound stage is really
impressive
oh look it's the dude
eliminate him just go over and [ __ ]
murder him really
there's a better way of doing this let's
see can we go can i go this way how are
you doing hey
i keep gone are you cool with that all
right
there's always a more interesting way of
killing somebody than just killing them
oh [ __ ] that guy see me
let's see what happened
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna save again
because i'm a massive [ __ ]
hey you guys enjoyed it seemed to be
having some fun
uh
i'm into this i
mean it's hard to judge a game on its
tutorial
it's pretty much the one level in which
it's more streamlined and nothing can
possibly go wrong
uh but i'm liking it controlling with
with the possible exception of that
weird little bug that happened the
it might have just been me being an
idiot come on somebody's gotta leave a
gun right here somewhere he did say the
weapons are simulated i love when she
said the weapons are simulated the
weapons are simulated when i threw that
wrench in that guy's [ __ ] head it was
just simulated don't worry about it it
wasn't actually his head
he's an android
can i look at this window
don't mind me guys yeah don't mind me
i'm just
just trying to figure i'm trying to
something there's a bolt back here that
needs
tightening so i'm just don't worry about
it
all right i'm gonna go upstairs i wonder
if there's like
like a rope i can
unhook that'll like so you tucked him in
dropped something on his head yeah what
did he say oh this fake helicopter is
great it's made of wood
locate the target i've lost oh here we
go that's what i want to do
i want to kill him with a fire
extinguisher obviously
i just throw the fire extinguisher from
here i mean it won't kill him
oh do you think this guy's got a gun
i think this guy's got a gun oh he does
he's got a gun watch this here we go
is he in view of anyone
beautiful day hey hey sunshine
this is probably gonna knock i don't
think this is blunt item enough
i don't think because it's not locking
onto his head so i'm gonna
go back and pick up my old friend
wait did i drop where is the wrench
disappeared or do i have an inventory
oh i have an infantry ooh i've got fiber
wire what am i doing
[ __ ] damn it [ __ ] it up
quick time events we're good
what can i do knock him out
pickup is gone
snap his neck
on your toes please you need to leave
now for your own sake whoa what
where's our dude he's over here okay
here we go
good night [ __ ]
don't worry about it
don't worry about it the guns are just
simulated
[ __ ]
run 47 you idiot are they looking for uh
they're looking for a cop i can't tell
i can't tell
i can't tell just run run
now head towards an exit i'm walking
towards an exit don't worry about it
hey buddy did you hear that i know
it's [ __ ] up right i heard a gunshot
that looks like okay i think i heard him
i think i heard i think i saw the purple
leave i got this wrench
i got this wrench i'm gonna no no
just gotta i just gotta find this i
gotta just gotta screw this pull back on
that's it
doink
haha
i am the hitman
wait i had a silenced pistol that whole
time
i can't wait to hear how i did
plus
how did you know
i told you he had talent
his stats are off the charts
such skills the second one still had
issues with people can only be the
result
i mean that's like the problem in all
these games right it's like
you're talking about it could be
dangerous such specifics when it comes
to human all ages
communication
perhaps it would be better to just
give me a chance sir
give him a chance i will take four give
me a chance i killed that guy and i got
out of there it was great what are you
talking about i just snapped some necks
as well on the way but you know
gotta enjoy it
as an ica agent every challenge you face
can be overcome in multiple ways okay
complete this exercise again this time
attacking it from a different angle
the sky
improvise all right we will be watching
i mean these games are all about
repetition before the final test you're
allowed one more time to practice the
ritter operation you're free to choose
your approach and you can use the
challenge guide challenges to guide you
we encourage you to complete as many as
possible all right what challenges we
got
poison the target with rat poison
distract a guard using a generator
throw a coin to cause a distraction what
is this assassin's creed
i hope it's not disguise yourself as
norfolk and meet with the target oh i
like it
classic hitman assassinate him with
fiber wire ironic
assassinate him by drowning him oh the
irony
board the yacht the sky is the security
guard
that's pretty good
join the crew find the yaku all right
place a weapon
and have a guard find it
why would you want to do that
assassinate the target with remote
explosives okay i like that one
flying the rat poison on dead zero i
guess i know where it is now hide the
target in a closet
only use
indian assassinate to target using the
life raft accident
so already it's giving us a bunch of
different ways to complete this mission
i mean
i thought my one was pretty good shoot
the [ __ ] in the head but sure whatever
we got a remote explosive
okay l1 and r1 to plant it you got a
lock pick
you'll probably throw it at people
a coin
is there multiple coins there are
multiple coins and multiple lockpicks
all right
all right ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls people of all descriptions uh if
you have any suggestions as to how i
should do this let me know
i like the explosive one especially okay
what i kind of want to do is just go up
there plant the explosive in the middle
of the party and see how the game reacts
to it so i'm probably going to do that
because well how long we in we're like
25 minutes into the stream i've probably
got another like
hour or so left i wanna these games are
sandboxes for a reason and
messing around with them is something
that's always fun so i'm just gonna
try to do a bunch of that stuff
trespassing this time i won't let this
guy find out what have i got what i got
lockpick oh i did have a silence pistol
the whole time whoops
fiber wire
whoa that animation is all over the
place but whatever
um
so interesting i'm not really sure about
how they
how they sort of uh use the controls
there it's left trigger to
get in a position to use the fireball
firewire fiber wire
gets sick internet um
but uh
but it was it was like square then to
actually eliminate it to to do it so i
don't know maybe maybe let's just zoom
in actually maybe i didn't need to do
that
i'm gonna leave him there i'm gonna i'm
not going to knock him out although his
eyes are open which
really suggests to me that he's already
[ __ ] dead but
is he dead oh he is that i use the
firework firewire of course i'm an idiot
sorry i'm being an idiot
so i guess he's dead i'm sorry
i'm sorry dead man
what the [ __ ]
look at this boat car park
before we take off yeah right
you guys are really committing to the
to the act i like it
all right deck zero i hear there's some
rot poison down here
hey mister who are you
oh
i've arrived suspiciously very polite
is he gonna come after me
hey what's up i'm just jerking off sorry
oh caught me what's up
what's up
hey you want to make out
what's up
[ __ ]
smacked him in the [ __ ] hand any all
right
sure is there somewhere i can hide this
guy
i thought he wanted to make out with me
i got a bit confused for a second
they are definitely going to find this
body by the way the 100
100 snap neck i don't want to snap his
neck i've already killed one person
what was suspicious about that
i'm a handyman
down here doing my thing turn off fuse
box yep
turn off the lights baby
classic hitman
how can i fix this trigger fire alarm no
i don't want to do that
it's a little bit too
much probably just one of the cylinders
look around the corner using the camera
all right let's use the coin oh [ __ ]
let's use the coin quick
sit down bro
subdue tapping square to subdue
where's the other guy gone i haven't
been using my spidey sense
okay let's drag him
in here
oh [ __ ]
don't worry about me is there morton
over here no all right jesus christ
hopefully these guys are just gonna stay
just stay there just keep working on
that yeah don't worry about it
don't worry about it you guys got it i
should probably pick this up so
nobody else uh no one else does
can i just have nothing in my hands can
i do that
is that all right
oh
all right hopefully they don't notice
i mean this rat poison idea now makes
less and less sense because
oh
if weapons are lying around a guard will
place him in a box like this
i'll keep him busy for a while okay so i
can
that's good to know oh i better pick my
coin up
i don't want to waste this
i'm earning good money but you know he's
got to keep you gotta can't do that
all right so here's the weapons crate i
guess if you
it's like it's like a safe spot
uh so the rat poison situation yeah
that's gonna be a bit problematic
because
i mean i've already got two bodies just
lying around here which are eventually
gonna get spotted you have to assume so
i mean doing something super subtle like
rat boys in there seems a little bit
redundant but we'll try what else what's
that crowbar
just go [ __ ] gordon freeman on all
these jerks
although these guys really do seem like
they're just gonna stand there the whole
time so maybe i'm all right
they got work to do
who am i to judge
rat poison
hey yeah and you guys know you keep the
rat poison around here we got some rats
up there upstairs
need to poison the [ __ ] out of them uh
yacht crew i fee i've been feeling this
disguise is a little bit more powerful
than the the other one
what's that oh yeah is that what i think
it is
rad poison
great
all right let's go upstairs
let's go upstairs and uh
add some of our special sauce to the
[ __ ] out there
keep painting
there's just one crew dudes who live by
the trader joe's near i live and they're
always painting over graffiti and i
secretly like every week because
somebody graffiti is the wall there and
i'm convinced that like they're he's
like sending his son down there to
graffiti a wall every day
like he's got them on a retainer
oh [ __ ] he's suspicious of me
oh [ __ ] stop
how do i run
how do i run how do i run la la la
is just la isn't it
oh [ __ ]
oh it's about to get [ __ ] real
let's save it and then
because i really want to use that
explosive
here we go here we go
i should have taken the yacht crew
uniform you're right
get down everyone
oh it's fake bullets
it's a distraction i've distracted
everyone
i really wish i knew there wasn't for
one oh it's r1 it's r1
stop hitting me with your fake bullets
oh i'm dead
well there you go now we know
load
i want to load downstairs there was an
auto save down there i know there was
you son of a [ __ ]
although honestly
these games are always super fun
when it comes i think is it that one i
think it's that one
autosaves yeah it's that one um these
games are always fun when you die it's
it's
they're good uh they're good they are
sandboxes that are worth replaying over
and over again so
we shall see
looks like the d-pad
might put your items away oh you're
right thank you very much sir cardinal
appreciate it my friend
yeah it is it's also it helps flick
between them
all right good to know good to know okay
let's get the uh i guess i gotta put
that uniform on
so that jerk hole upstairs and think i'm
doesn't get all suspicious i should have
known there was an icon over the guy in
fairness can i run then we'll get
suspicious yeah we're good um
there was an icon over him which
suggested that he was special in a way
to everyone else so that's
that's good to know i wonder if
yeah
i mean
sorry excuse me that is par for the
course for some of the for hitman as
well is that
people within the same rank as you may
have uh
may have a little bit of trouble
or we may be able to recognize you okay
there's two ways you do this right one
and knock this guy out and i put the rap
poison in myself two
i somehow like distract him and do it
let's try that
i'm gonna try to distract him hey don't
worry i'm just gonna throw a coin over
here
uh not pursuing a career in sports are
you
okay
don't worry about me then
i'll just pick up this coin i got
i should use the remote explosive that'd
be a good idea
that animation is never having fun
all right
close it up
where's my rock boys or not
what
how do i put it in
oh i put it in you son of a [ __ ]
weird if i zoom in or like the audio
goes away well that's a little bit
annoying
am i missing a trickier video game
is it not here i'm supposed to be
putting in the rat poison
i mean this is rat poison right
emetic rat poison yeah
look how he's carrying it what the
[ __ ] going on it's like a box just
hanging out of the head of his hand
what
i don't understand how are you holding
it like that
well that's [ __ ] frustrating uh
great i don't know what to do there
what's this over here
it's just a wrench
well that didn't work so i guess
oh god damn it let me see if there's any
other way of using the wrap poison
maybe there's a
way of him drinking it or something
but newspaper
are you gonna drink that where is he
where's our dude where's our dude maybe
maybe it's not in the food maybe it's in
his
in his drink or something
if i get if i poison this and then
bring it up to him
don't mind me
nope i guess i've just killed some
random person
great
okay he's uh he's having a meeting
hopefully i can kill him before
someone else drinks that wine
hmm
how does he keep saying evidence removed
i'm interested in that
are they finding stuff that i dropped
nobody's going to drink that glass of
wine
what's up
where's that dude he was gonna meet
well it's that guy in there he's already
met him oh there's the thing okay give
me a sec give me a sec i know what to do
i know what to do i'm just gonna run
upstairs
i got some sea [ __ ] to do upstairs don't
worry about me i'm just a sea captain
having a cc time
here we go environmental deaths are the
quintessential
hitman situation
oh [ __ ] missing crowbar god damn it
god damn it
hopefully they're having a really long
conversation we can just run the whole
way downstairs
don't mind me
just going down there's get my crowbar
where's it at though
where was it where was it
it was in
[ __ ] it was back here it was back here
isn't this room
crowbar
perfect
hide it away
really getting my workout done today you
guys still haven't figured out that
body's there great all right just keep
yeah keep it up
that's why we pay you the big bucks
we got over here
hey what's up man on the c yep you know
it
this this would be ironic as well
actually every every way of this guy's
death is ironic
uh i need to get rid of this [ __ ]
dude though
oh [ __ ] you got to be kidding me
drop him [ __ ] it let's just see if he's
hopefully still standing there
is he
god damn it
it's all going wrong
where's our boy
where's he gone
yeah question mark i know i could have
killed you
[ __ ] he go
god damn it
great he's over there now he's just
hanging out
hopefully he's standing under another
another
[ __ ]
god damn i can't believe it where is he
he's in there okay he's hanging out
give me a second it's just on the tip of
my tongue
i slipped your mind
happens to my wife all the time oh
because of the alzheimer's glass cutter
here we go here we go
hey folks
impressive yeah i like that uniform
thanks you can't come through here right
okay don't worry about it saw this
painting an original gorka
thing is i could have sworn it was
stolen from the story besides
understood
don't worry about me i'm just the
captain of the ship with a gun don't
worry about it
excuse me right there
fake surrender
that's right
okay
yeah kicking the balls [ __ ]
psych
and the perfect crime was complete
okay okay
okay what's my best work
let's try it again
god damn it
i like the fake a fake um
surrender that was
good mission accomplished
spare change
join the crew
yeah i did all these things i didn't
actually use the rap boys in the right
way though i just poisoned some random
socialite
final test [ __ ] it
i think i'm ready
do they think i'm ready probably not
i just got word romania was a dead end
i'm fired thanks
thanks master place is real enough
deserted but we found no trace that your
man was ever there or anyone else for
that matter
someone erased his steps
digging of course but frankly it's as if
the earth just spat him out
are you still determined does it matter
i was told there'd be no second chances
don't believe everything you hear don't
believe the hybrid
my decision stands
very
well i'll be watching ooh so will i i
wonder if they've changed what happened
to her in absolutely final test is based
on an authentic 1979 mission the high
point of training director soda's career
as an active agent
the target was jasper knight a famous us
chess master exposed as a soviet spy
[ __ ] was caught up with night at
a military airfield in cuba and
eliminated him against all odds this is
your objective as well
now listen carefully i'm listening ica
exams aren't normally this difficult
not only was the airfield a virtual
fortress he even added additional guards
that's a [ __ ] sodas wants you to
fail so does you a threat and this way
your unfortunate exit from the program
will not raise any eyebrows it's gonna
be really easy to find him he did not
however factor me into the equation he's
the only one in that building that looks
like an [ __ ] can bend the rules then
so can i great good luck initially
thanks
friend
okay what i got i got fiber wire silent
special coins
we're doing great
uh one thing to take into mind if you
just started watching the stream is that
this is a
this is set up in a way that it is
these are training missions so the
levels are kind of supposed to look like
jank it's not like it's
like these are final areas or anything
eavesdropping ooh
let's drop some eaves
you really have to do this
what did i learn where is it where is it
hidden
nope hit the wrong button there
middle one
intel
training director soldier
oh and they have a bunch of uh so every
mission i guess has all these challenges
assassinate jasper by drowning him that
seems to be a familiar
situation in these games uh electric hit
him all right
as he investigates the projector very
good
set the kgb officer up to electrocute
the target while he investigates the
projector is that the same one or just
slightly different
i said lots of different ways to do it
there's also challenges for this stuff
for
discovery
so basically just like
i think these are essentially ways that
the game is telegraphing you
ideas of how to play it yeah
cool
would you like to track this opportunity
sure what opportunity is this fighter
jet
sounds dangerous
it's pretty good all right
so if i go get that clip forward i can
find out how to do a fighter jet
and then i can escape via fighter jet
that's kind of weird but i like it
all right why do you think the distance
is on this thing you know i gotta knock
somebody out from here
am i gonna have to get this guy to turn
around
yo you want a penny penny for your
thoughts
what
what
money
oh [ __ ] i went the wrong way
hmm
don't worry about that i'll just hit you
in the head with this hammer
ah screw that
how did i not go over the fence also is
this guy blind he just can't see me all
right
let's try that again
i guess it was not gonna go over there
perfect
there we go yeah turn around
[ __ ]
weird
is there another way in over here
another crowbar i'm going to use the
chrome crowbar seems to be useful
for more than bludgeoning
can't get over the top all right
swap slides that guy's still there
spidey vision yeah [ __ ] man all right
i guess i'm just scared by what the view
distance is on these guys
can i hit that guy in the head with the
hammer from here
ah
well this has gone well oh [ __ ] can i
dress up as that guy no all right i'll
just wait now i'll just hide here
he's aiming for the head oh [ __ ] you
weren't dead why were dead
all right let's see let's see if we can
brute force our way into this
god dammit
i'm better than this i'm better than
this
let's get past this
goddamn gate
no this is not my first hit man
i'm a long time fan of the series
i've
completed it
almost all of them i wasn't too much of
a fan of absolution because 79
but yeah trying to get this i'm trying
to get past this [ __ ] is like my
situation i guess
i guess i just need to get the guy in
there's
uniform
let's try that again i might just be
taking my sweet time with it too
much right
let's get the
eavesdropping find out about the jet
again
did you print out the safety protocol oh
i can vault over the top of this i can
just straight up vault over this one
they're gonna see me though
plus i should probably have a security
outfit if i get in there
is there anywhere else i can get over it
let's try that
let's see what happens
i don't care which one it it's mandatory
just take the box and get it done wow
okay
yes i will track that opportunity thanks
for asking once again
sounds dangerous
okay there's a dude over there
these guys are walking
super batman crisis vision tells me the
target's over there
massive hero makes good point there's
always good alternate routes in hitman
games that's true it's i think one of
the interesting things about how they're
gonna release this game is that
hopefully people uncover really crazy
obscure ways
of completing the game
[ __ ]
come here baby come here baby
good boy
there's a good boy all right
this guy's there
pick up his gun
and we're good
okay
where do i want to go next
let's go in here and see if there's
anything worth picking up
turn on the radio that's just gonna
be used to alert people hey what's up
hopefully that guy doesn't notice
anything
okay where's the way into the building
so he's back there so i'm guessing
there's no entrance there i wonder if
these security guards probably aren't
allowed
go into the building right these are
these are like outside security guys
let's take a look
i mean that soldier there is probably
the guy to take right
him or his buddy him or the other guy
he's right there who's got a the guy
with the kalashnikov
it just it's it's always hard in these
games right when you start off to
understand to like try and
figure out where exactly the
like the line of sight is for some of
these dudes
so what i could do is when that guy
12 o'clock from where i am now
walks past i can just hit his buddy here
with a hammer in the back of the head
because this guy's got a [ __ ]
insane pitching arm
and then quickly bundled him out of
there let's try
nope
oh great i'm clear
you [ __ ] serious
you serious
well okay
is that guy there is he gonna notice oh
[ __ ]
keep walking keep walking [ __ ] you found
the gun
okay is that real
oh [ __ ] it is real what's real
he's gonna kill all the guards i'll just
go kill kill all the guards
how many people do you think i could fit
in that box
i should probably snap his neck right
this [ __ ] wakes up i'm gonna be so
angry
[ __ ]
someone notice
he's just going for sleep don't worry
about it
[ __ ] hell
one by one
we sure do we sure do we got it
[ __ ] hell how many of these guys are
left
i'm gonna kill everyone it's here
okay i snapped his neck
i've got it i've i've decided that next
snapping is now cool again how many
people can i fit in
here that's two let's see if we can get
four
so i'm gonna snap your neck
the only guy whose neck hasn't been
snapped is the dude that's already in
that bin but he's gonna wake up with
like three other guys on top of him so i
think we're gonna be okay
i'll be honest i'm really surprised that
the ai let me get away with that one
okay no i can't
there is a limit on the amount of people
you can put on a box apparently
good to know
i'm just gonna drag this guy in this
general direction
no one's gonna look back here
now i gotta pick up like 12 kalashnikovs
or their m16s right yeah
all right let's pick it up fusel
got this hammer
pick up this gun snap this neck
whoa
drag this dude
i'm enjoying this though
it's uh it feels
it's hard to tell so early i feel like
i'm getting away with a lot but then the
game isn't going to be pressing me super
hard in a tutorial you know what i mean
like
it's kind of what's not to be expected
if you just joined uh welcome to
twitch.tv forward slash game spot
or if you're watching this on
gamespot.com or if you're watching this
on youtube gaming gamespot uh channel
over there thank you for joining us
everyone and we're broadcasting this all
over the goddamn place uh this is
hitman's beta
on the playstation 4. it's open today
february 12th uh sorry it's not it's not
open it is for people who have
pre-ordered the game and then if you're
lucky enough to get a code i guess it's
on pc next week and this is the new
game from io interactive and square enix
the hitman that is coming out that's got
the strange sort of episodic release
schedule they're doing you may have read
about it the man is like a sitting duck
staying in cuba it's only a matter of
time before langley catches up with
right that was knight
poison it's [ __ ] everywhere
now he wants his girlfriend so i guess i
know how to explain via jet or sorry get
out be a jet which is pretty crazy
where's our buddy he's up there
here we go what difficulty i do not
believe the tutorial has a difficulty
this uh this whole
this is a prequel sort of setting so
this is all set before the first hitman
game although they've also
changed i mean absolution change stuff
as well but
they have changed a bunch of stuff i'm
going to go upstairs and see if there's
any way down into his room oh music just
cut that was interesting
maybe because of this guy
[ __ ]
that may have been an opportunity oh our
friend is coming out you kidding me
wow okay
don't worry me i'm just sitting here
yep
hanging out
nothing suspicious at all like i just
throw them over the top
well that was my opportunity when can i
go in here probably not right
i'll probably freak out if i go in here
maybe not
all right and we got a cup of coffee you
want some rap poison in
i mean there's a there's a whole oh what
tamper
tamper with the chess game oh [ __ ]
i'll just leave it don't worry
hey buddy
[ __ ] someone's coming i would have had
it i would have had it
security guard's coming back in
is that his drink
[ __ ] i don't know which one
well i don't think they've uh i think
he's drank all the vodka already
yeah i'm just hanging out bro don't
worry about it
there's a lot of people moving in and
out is that room over there empty maybe
wait hey
could it be so simple
ah no
i seem to be able to walk around free
and easy up here
without raising any suspicion more rat
poison jesus christ how much rat poison
is in the world of him man
yep that's what i that's the game we're
playing brother in arms hell's highway
that's it right here
oh man
okay poison both you think i don't know
i i feel like they've already drank the
vodka also it's in front of all these
people i just go over and [ __ ] with this
chess game
it's a little weird that i'm just about
to stand here and there's nothing like
hey what's going on
oh [ __ ] i don't think you should be
doing that sorry i didn't mean to do
that
well i went i actually meant to hit the
button that was talk to him but then i
just punched him in the face so
snap his neck
let's drag this [ __ ] is anyone
else coming back over this way
no we're good okay well with that i
guess look i improvised right i am
provided
let's get this guy in here
[ __ ] snap this guy's neck or dragon
is he gonna let me snap his neck that's
a pretty good cool way to kill this guy
snap his [ __ ] neck
done
unnoticed kill
put him in there
pick up the gun
[ __ ] with his chest game a little bit
just while we're you know moving out and
it's gonna move queen to g3
checkmate [ __ ]
all right let's go here
so can i actually leave with the jet is
that a possibility because they said
that i may have learned how to do that
maybe not
what did it say they say there was some
sort of information i needed to
acquire
it appears that all fighter jet
passengers are required to do an onboard
safety check before takeoff the protocol
is performed by airplane mechanics and
is listed on the clipboard
so i guess i needed to knock one of
those guys out to do that
that would have been a cool way to get
out but i guess i irised that one up so
the only way out is
the front door do you think anyone's
going to check on him
there's a lot of footfall through that
room for a while and there is no one so
we just try and get in the jet
see what happens
yeah maybe not
[ __ ] so the white dot over the head i
think are the guys who are going to
notice if i'm
not one of them
so including all these [ __ ] people
god damn it
oh [ __ ]
okay i need to get some sort of disguise
on
where did i put the other disguise
[ __ ] i thought i had it in the bag
i thought i had it in the bag
wait i did i got him with a soldier's
uniform didn't i
i walked past him with a soldier's
uniform so i should be able to walk back
out with a soldier's uniform maybe it's
because i was running
oh is that the clipboard
is that the clipboard
jasper knight certainly knows how to
make an exit but first he needs to test
the jet safety equipment
including the ejector seat
huh
can i use the ejector seat
there's a button underneath there what
am i doing can i crawl under
why is that little dot there [ __ ]
i'm intrigued now
so i guess if i was a mechanic i'll be
able to put that
work are we one to go over the safety
protocol yeah go ahead i disabled the
ejector seat mechanism good man
missing wrench
okay
here we go
oh [ __ ] i've already killed him there's
no point hey you yeah you
i don't know you
damn it
i thought i could eject i just want to
check something don't worry about it i'm
all right i'm good i'm good to go i'm
good to go
[ __ ]
let's just try and get out of here
so i guess i could adjust when he was
leaving i could have
done the
triggered the ejector seat and killed
him that way he's gonna walk out this
way
that guy didn't see nothing he didn't
see nothing
see if i can walk can i vault over this
[ __ ] yeah i can't
all right
see this is the thing right if i was
doing this i would go back and play this
level again and try and do it a
different way
boom
i'm a [ __ ] hitman baby
you are cleared for field duty
there you go
i think that's when the beta ends if i'm
not incorrect
i hope you know what you just did
you just let a bald guy become a hitman
what a dumb tattoo now get out of my
sight
so what happens now
you go back into the world disappear
stay on your own and on the move when we
need you we will contact you
and so does
he play his hand sodas are delicious
he cannot touch us now
still i can't believe we beat him at his
own game if you know your enemy
quite right
i should tell you the trail went dead
after romania our team found no records
of any kind no name
nothing
i think they called me 47.
that's
not a name
so make it one
his name was tobias
agent
47.
there you go
season premieres march for 11th 2016.
this is the playstation 4 beta of hitman
the hitman game that's coming out this
year um
let me make sure to get this thing up oh
yeah the beta open on pc sorry not open
i keep saying open i don't know what i'm
talking about it's the soda got it uh
the playstation 4 one is open today for
people who have pre-ordered it on pc you
can get into that if you pre-ordered the
game on pc as well uh
okay so i'm a big fan of the original
games i like how difficult they were i
like how the demo for the first game
was one that took you
like i was playing as a teenager
so like it took me a long long time to
complete it and then certainly to master
it it took a long time so it's difficult
to judge this game off of that i mean if
the if the levels are as easy and
forgiving as that one is
then
i feel like that's
it's going to be difficult to be playing
a mission a month if that's the way that
they're going to be releasing these
things um
but taking this as a tutorial
like yeah i get it like okay it's not
particularly
challenging but
maybe they're just trying to teach you
how to play the game a little bit um i'm
actually interested to see if i can go
back in and change difficulty settings
there was nothing on the initial menu
that suggested that there's anything
like that
and i mean like how they're gonna change
people noticing you like i mean that's
gotta be stuff that's locked in pretty
heavily right
uh nice options i mean it's very hit
manny like
a lot of this is well trodden grounds
like using rat poison environmental
deaths
getting back to your silver ballers
i mean you really got one of them this
time uh but using those when things go
to [ __ ]
and then you know
oftentimes that being really not much of
a good situation to be in like blood
money was a game that i felt like you
couldn't really get away with that a lot
of the time and it wasn't really fun
either like they intentionally sort of
make it not that difficult um i'm
wondering what you guys think though in
the in the chat i i obviously was
keeping an eye on this mostly so i i
couldn't really spend too much time uh
mission a month so the way i believe
they're doing this and they were going
to release the game back in december of
last year got pushed back a little bit
and then the original plan i believe was
that they were going to release a game
and then have
sort of supplemental add-on stuff
for it but the base game is going to
have a decent amount of stuff in it now
the way they're doing it is that they're
going to release it episodically which
is that they're going to release the
game what i believe the prologue we just
saw there and then the paris mission
which i think is the one that's got
we've seen a bunch of d3 which is the
one with like it looks like zoolander
basically um the fashion show and all
that i think that's the paris level
and then basically they're going to
trickle out so you can buy this starter
pack which i think it's just those and
then you can buy further missions as dlc
or they're going to sell like a digital
version
which is like a full digital version
which is going to give you access to
everything they release over the course
of the year and it sounds like they've
got stuff found right up until december
of 2016 like loads of these missions
that they've been talking about and then
once they've done that they're going to
release a physical copy with everything
on it so
that apparently is is the way that
they're going to be launching it uh from
what i saw of the paris level it looked
a lot bigger than anything on this
tutorial level like these very much seem
like smaller ones so i think judging the
game off of
i mean you can judge a lot off of this
you can judge how it controls and it
controls pretty well you know jail looks
and it looks fine we're on the
playstation 4. i mean it looks fine for
ps4 game i play games on pc mostly
so
like it's you know the frame rate was
relatively okay it looked not like none
of it seemed like it was jaggy to me i
wonder if it was maybe a little more
jaggy on the stream because it was in 30
frames a second and this was on felt
like it was on 60 anyway um
i'm interested to see what the ps or the
pc one looks like that'll be open on the
19th which is uh seven days from today
if you're watching this is for friday if
you're watching this on demand
so
yeah i think that would be telling as
well hopefully io have always made good
looking pc games obviously a lot of
there's been a lot of turnover in that
studio so this is perhaps not a lot of
the people who worked on those old games
but uh yeah i'm interested
certainly as a fan of hitman this feels
very hit manny it feels very familiar
whether or not these games are as good
as
some of the high caliber games like
hitman one and two were pretty fantastic
games blood money is up there as like
one of the best
like third-person action games ever as
far as i'm concerned it's certainly one
of the best stealth games ever made so
they have a heart a high water mark to
hit and it's too hard to judge off this
tutorial if that's what they've managed
to do yet but yeah first time i played
it i think i'm on fan i've never touched
this one in all the preview events and
uh yeah i actually really enjoyed it and
i'm definitely going to play a little
bit more of this i was a little bit
worried going into it to be honest and
uh yeah i'm like pleasantly surprised
uh sounds alright actually i probably
only pay 15 worth it anyway yeah i mean
they're gonna be launching it like at a
pretty low price point from the start so
that's uh that's your way to do it uh
losing the silver ballers was my least
favorite part of absolution
um
each month gets a new sandbox that's
kind of the way you know but that is
kind of the way it seems to be going i'd
be interested
it probably would be too hard to make
user created stuff for a game like this
right there's probably so much scripting
involved
um franco says yeah you can also pay for
an upgrade from the intro pack to a full
game that's good to know so i guess if
you buy that intro pack for 15 bucks
and then you want to upgrade you don't
be stuck in a situation
where you're like buying all the dlc
because you have to imagine that if you
accumulate all that stuff after the fact
chances are it's going to cost more than
the full version like buying it as a
pack it's just
the way that stuff usually works
uh ben underscore game score i'm
intrigued as to how the release
structure will affect the amount of
people that will play this game
it's a very good point because
they're like i feel like action games
like this like games like actually such
a broad term but games like
you know tomb raider or just cause like
you tend to play these games in one go
and then if you don't if you break away
from them for a week the chances are
you're never [ __ ] coming back it's
like the witcher if you try and complete
the witcher over like months and months
and months some people can do it but
it's quite difficult whereas if you dive
into it or like you're solid
you'll keep playing so it's yeah it's
going to be interesting to see how that
works i wonder if they're going to drop
the packs at moments where there's not
much going on like post e3 when there's
not like
june july sort of lull
like if they drop a bunch of dlc in the
middle of november like is anyone gonna
care are they gonna have all that stuff
released so they can release their
physical copy in november i guess we'll
we'll find out pretty soon uh there will
be user contracts you can share with
friends in the community oh i actually
had no idea about that celtic kennedy
um
what's the story about
so that was that was set before
that that set before one but that's
that's set before anything
and also it the story from one with is
clearly just not they don't use anymore
from absolution and
like this that the cloning [ __ ] is all
is all gone so i mean i'm sure if they
used on the movies i've never i haven't
seen either the movies i can't believe
there's two hitman
what the [ __ ]
um
but uh yeah it's like yes without
getting into spoilers for the old games
it looks like you're you're back with
your old fixer and
uh from what i understand the
game hitman 2016 hitman game is set
after absolution so put the prequel set
before it because that was like a
training mission
uh so that was 20 years before yeah but
but
franco but the the stuff is actually the
the full game was played after
absolution from what i know
from press releases on wikipedia
uh why man what if they made a huge
suburban sandbox i mean so much of this
game is based on scripted events it's
based on like people getting into
certain spots like
they have to be able to you know set up
the game so that you have enough time to
get the crowbar to go upstairs by the
time he's there
and they also can't have people like in
loops because it wouldn't make sense if
he was to go upstairs and talk to the
guy and then go downstairs and start the
whole thing again so
i guess there's a lot of like micro
design happening in these games so
it'd be kind of hard to
but but i'm interested as well like how
big is the biggest
world they have in this game
uh all right i'm gonna leave it there
thank you so much for joining today
twitch.tv forward slash gamespot or if
you're watching on gamespot.com we're
watching on youtube gaming
i think it's gamespot.youtube.com i
forget how that one works
gaming.youtube.com is that right
probably um i'm danny dwyer from
gamespot.com thank you so much for
watching for more coverage of hitman the
beta and beyond stay tuned to
gamespot.com we have i don't think we
have any more live streams today there's
a bunch of stuff going up on the website
i'm working on an overwatch
preview which should be up later i know
mary is previewing a game today which
i'm not sure if she can talk about maybe
and for those who have been into the
gamespot rocket league pro am uh josh
shaw is currently trying to figure out
some way of
streaming the ultimate finals which i
believe is between myself and julio and
the winner of matt padgett
chris pereira i think and eric tay and
who's tay's
teammate
oh ryan schubert i think so that's going
to be there as well thanks so much have
a great weekend if you're in america
enjoy the long weekend president's day
of course on monday if your state is i
think all states
have a look at that right yeah i think
so uh yeah and thanks so much for
hanging out really appreciate it hit
that follow button hit that subscribe
button and we'll see you next time here
on game spot adios
that's the wrong button whatever